lady white am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
woody I have a question
well actually not just one I have all
the questions who wants to go on a road
trip you need help with that no no I got
it oh this is a little strange but we
all have to make sure nothing happens to
four key buzz we gotta get port Roger
that
[Music]
change of plans jessie half but both rex
potato hey watch it buddy let's go save
a spork do I need to be worried
my guys are veterans they'll hang in
there
Oh
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man
oh yeah posing yeah quick hold on one
more oh yeah save me I've known that guy
my whole life today's
[Music]
is that how we look on inside so much
body needs fortune Oh Sheriff would you
always come in to the rescue that's
gonna be quite a jump for you and Duke
committee
let's kaboom
Porky's being kept how do we get that
key what about the old plush rush there
you go oh where did you two come from
well we're not doing that
[Music]
you